le mini vaille la parole est à monsieur
olivier marc l'ex merci monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux à
l'issue du conseil des ministres du 23
décembre le premier ministre nous a
annoncé que 250 djihadistes était de
retour de syrie ou d'irak
ma question est simple que comptez vous
faire pour que ces individus soient
punis comme il le mérite après avoir
combattu dans les rangs de l'état
islamique après avoir combattu l'armée
française et surtout pour protéger nos
compatriotes
depuis les attentats de janvier vous
avez en effet refusé toute mesure de
rétention administrative à l'encontre de
ces criminels ils sont donc libres
d'aller et de venir sur notre territoire
dans nos quartiers comme bon leur semble
aucune circulaire de votre part n'a
donné d'instruction magistrat
quant au sort qu'il fallait leur
réserver au contraire votre circulaire
du 5 décembre 2014
prise en application de la loi
terrorisme rappelle que les magistrats
doivent appliquer la présomption
d'innocence puisque le fait d'avoir
séjourné sur un théâtre d'opération ne
suffit pas à caractériser une infraction
c'est vrai que la syrie est une
destination touristique très en vogue
de toutes évidences madame la ministre
ces instructions sont inadaptées à
l'horreur des crimes et de la barbarie
perpétrés par ces individus notamment
pourquoi les chrétiens et contre
l'église y dit personne ne peut dire
qu'ils ignorent ces crimes
un jugement rendu cette semaine par le
tribunal correctionnel de paris a
seulement condamné un djihadiste je veux
dire à six ans de prison
refusant la période de sûreté pour
ménager je cite sa volonté de
réinsertion
elle a de quoi reconnaissait le nous
inquiéter quel message d'absence de
fermeté il existe pourtant dans notre
code pénal des dispositifs relative aux
crimes de guerre au génocide réveillant
des peines très lourdes de réclusion
criminelle à peine 8 t elles valent
aussi pour les complices ce sont ces
pénale qu'il faut appliquer alors madame
le ministre je vous demande de nous dire
où sont ces 250 individus qu'elle est
qu'elles sont les poursuites pénales qui
seront engagées contre eux
merci la parole est à mme monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
s'il vous plaît allez retrouver votre
calme je vous ai le ministre c'est le
gouvernement qui vous plaît ici elle est
le ministre qui répond vous le savez
allez monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier pour
la chaleur de votre accueil qui me va
droit au coeur
c'est toujours agréable sur les sujets
les plus importants qui devraient
appeler le rassemblement le plus grand
que de voir des polémiques inutiles
poindre mais la lutte contre le
terrorisme vous le savez bien
monsieur j avoue elle l'engagement de
nombreux ministères et sur la question
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
le ministère de la justice et le
ministère de l'intérieur comme en
témoigne l'excellence des relations
entre le parquet antiterroriste françois
molas et les services de police agissent
de concert
alors vous me posez une question
extrêmement précise et je vais y
répondre il y à 250 personnes qui sont
revenus sur le théâtre des opérations
terroristes après le retour de décence
de ceux de ses 250 personnes il ya eu 2
132 interpellation il a eu 168
incarcération il y a eu 60 contrôle
judiciaire par conséquent monsieur marc
l'ex lorsque vous laissez entendre à la
représentation nationale et par
conséquent aux français qu'il n'y aurait
pas de fermeté face au terrorisme qui
rentre d opération terroriste
après ce que je vais vous indiquez vous
maniez la contrevérité et le sujet de la
lutte contre le terrorisme mérite
beaucoup mieux que les contre-vérités et
les mises en cause
un juge de ministres qui comme la garde
des sceaux sur la question de la lutte
contre le terrorisme donnent le meilleur
d'eux mêmes prennent les décisions qui
doivent être prises et les français de
ces baux et à les arts et la
détermination qui est la nôtre et qui
savent que cette détermination sera sur
le métier jour après jour car la guerre
contre le terrorisme nous la gagnerons
merci monsieur